[Music]
okay we'll get started so I want to talk
about we're continuing on singular value
decomposition
we'll do that also the next two lectures
Monday and Wednesday next week so we
already saw what it is but I'm going to
recap a little bit but go on a little
bit right so we just showed that every
matrix can be decomposed into a sum like
that where the utn VTR rectus the VTR
also normal so we always have this Sigma
T u T V T transpose so remember that
this is an outer product u T the about
column vectors u T this is V T transpose
so each of them is a matrix it's a
decomposition into rank one matrices the
Sigma T is always or are always
non-negative actually we assume it's
positive we don't write the zeros now
this rate I want to illustrate lots of
uses of just the fact that the VT are
orthonormal so so far we already have
that the VT are orthonormal that's what
I will assume but later we'll show that
the UT are orthonormal to
now the VTR orthonormal by definition
because they said by definition because
we said V 2 is the maximizing vector
perpendicular to V 1 so they are
orthonormal right UT are not by
definition because they were defined as
u T equals a times V T divided by the
length so there's no reason no immediate
reason why UT should be also normal so
we will have to prove that but even the
fact that VTR orthonormal do you'll be
able to use I'll show you some context
and some context I'll just mention right
so I mean we we just sort of worked this
out but this is a bit of a recap a a
transpose I want to tell you what it is
I mean it comes out to be that on the
face of it there are our turns here are
terms there that should that will be a
total of our squared terms when I
multiply out but of course the
non-identical terms cancel out so let me
just write one more step here in the
middle so I'm going to multiply them out
so that's t1 t2 going from 1 to R Sigma
T 1 Sigma T 2 I will get UT 1 VT 1
transpose V t2 UT to transpose okay so
these don't necessarily commute here
matrices you have to write them in order
except you notice that this is a scalar
right so this is the dot product as a
scalar so that of course can be brought
out or whatever you want to do with it
this is 0 again if t1 is not equal to t2
I put a word of caution that if instead
of inner product you are now the product
that's not true right so we saw it last
night so these all go go out if t1 is
not equal to c2 only t1 equals t2 counts
so only the cross terms go away and then
you get that right so this we saw
I'll show you something new but in a
minute we also saw that if a is
invertible then R equals the full
dimension is d as all the Sigma T's or
non zero and the inverse of it is one
over Sigma T VT u T transpose I have to
show you that that that is the inverse
so we take a times that matrix and show
that that's identity V T UT transpose
and I want to show that this is the
identity that's enough right - so show
that that's inverse so you just write
expand you expand a again you put T 1
Sigma T 1 UT 1 VT 1 transpose it's
really the same thing 1 over Sigma T and
here you just have VT 2 UT 2 transpose
and again you expand these two but this
times this is 0 ok
and that's again in the product right so
this times that is 0 once you expand it
out right so we just expand it out like
we did this and so this is the identity
so you get sorry excuse me I'm not done
yet
just complete this picture just so
that's equal to UT UT transpose over all
T and that's just the identity written
to the basis UT right so change your
basis so the way you sort of see that
this is identity is if I hit with any X
where they expand X on this basis and
you'll get X back okay so you do have to
do this little calculation so I could
take any set of full orthonormal vectors
full set of orthonormal vectors and UT
UT transpose summed over this is the
identity so the normal identities when
you tease are all the unit vectors
okay a may not have an inverse and often
this pseudo inverse is quite useful if a
is singular it always has the pseudo
inverse again I only wrote this for
Sigma T's that are not zero
I wrote it only for Sigma T is not 0 so
I can take 1 over Sigma T and I've just
transposed it I put V T UT transpose
just like you do for the inverse right
there's a transpose it wall so if again
I'm going to check by multiplication I
multiply a with that right cross terms
go away Sigma T times 1 minus 1 over
Sigma T is 1 and you just get UT UT
transpose this is the identity but not
on all of space right so again maybe
it's worth saying pointing that out so
now we have UT UT transpose these are
orthonormal but not a full set R is less
than the matrix UT by the way was on
that side so it's n by 1 matrix is 1 by
n ok R is less than n so this acting on
an X equal to 0 if X is orthogonal to
the span of the UTS so if you have
something orthogonal to all the UT is it
0 right because it makes a 0 right and
it's the identity on the span of the UTS
and that is a proof right so it is
identity but on a subspace okay now so
in linear algebra probably you know you
have all seen spectral decomposition so
any symmetric matrix any hermitian
matrix can be written as sum of t equals
1 to R lambda T lambda T or eigen values
they don't have to be positive lambda T
UT UT transpose
where the UT's are also normal now right
so eigen vectors which are orthogonal
okay so you can write it in spectral
decomposition we can prove that which
with one assumption from SVD that's this
simple proof so suppose you you look at
me to see symmetric matrices a and I do
SVD a don't do spectral decomposition I
want to get spectral decomposition from
a sweetie
so I do a sweetie and AC SVD is T equals
1 to our Sigma T u T V T transpose let
say I assume they sweetie had no ties
okay that that's where that's the case I
can prove very easily spectral
decomposition from a sweetie
in these two steps now I cannot assume
no ties there can be plus minus one ties
so what that note I says is there exists
a unique pair of vectors V 1 minus V 1
such that AV is maximized by them right
this is how we define the first singular
vector best fit line right so that's
equal to V 1 or minus V 1 so I cannot
avoid having two of them I always will I
can always put a negative sign that's
alright but I will say by no ties that
informally that there are only plus
minus okay so if that's the case we have
a proof right so because a is equal to a
transpose symmetric so that implies a is
also equal to Sigma T V T UT transpose
so I've taken that and transposed it
so we T came to the front and UT
transpose right
no ties implies like we said V 1 was
unique
here we've got a u1 the length is the
same right there it's the length of okay
maybe I should have made that remark
well we know that for any vector X when
I hit it with X as the links will be the
same
therefore this u1 also should be a max
so you one better be plus or minus v1
okay so we have to pause for a moment we
can make a mistake here right we can say
no ties means u 1 must be equal to V 1
so that is not necessarily true if you
weren't we're equal to V 1 always all
the eigenvalues would be positive
because all the singular values are
positive right so this actually says the
eigenvalues are plus or minus or
singular values for for symmetric
matrices right there they're already
real the eigenvalues are symmetric
meters are always already real but it
says there are plus or minus or singular
values okay so this proves that you can
get spectral decomposition of a
symmetric matrix now spectral
decomposition of a symmetric matrix is
useful and I'm going to mention two
important examples in a minute it's
useful for a lot of context actually so
let's take a power of high power of the
matrix s I claim that it's just this is
symmetric now right its spectral
decomposition I'm going to take a high
power I mean better be at least square
before it take powers rectangular
matrices I can't take powers but if I
take a high power then only the
eigenvalues get powered the eigenvectors
remain the same right we can see that by
just multiplying out so maybe what since
I have not so many slides I can do all
these calculations so abs is sum over T
1 equals 1 to R lambda T 1 u T 1 u T 1
transpose then you have T 2 and so on
I could expand this out I mean you could
also prove the induction there are s
brackets like that so t1 through TS I
get lambda T 1 lambda t 2 lambda TS now
this thing becomes u t1 u t1 transpose
then you get a t2 then you get a t3 but
these are all scalars they're all inner
products right so the community come out
and so on so forth
but they're all 0 I mean sorry one of
them is 0 everything is 0 so you better
have t1 equals t2 equals C 3 equals TS
otherwise at least one of if even one
pair differs it's 0 dot product is 0 so
the whole thing is 0 so you only get
terms where they're all equal so that
becomes just sum over T lambda T to the
S of course you knew that the
eigenvalues of powers of matrices or
powers you also knew that the
eigenvectors are the same right if a a V
is equal to lambda V a to the SV is also
equal to lambda SV so you need that but
this is just saying that expanding but
now I want to say something non-trivial
and again that's that's extremely useful
so let's see why that's true okay
so I want to claim that if lambda 1 is a
unique eigenvalue with the greatest
absolute value so in words lambda 1 is
the unique eigenvalue will greatest
magnitude
so no ties no multiple eigenvalues with
the highest absolute value you could
have that for a matrix right we are
assuming that that is not the case for
instance if you had the identity all the
eigenvalues of the same absolute value
one right so I'm ruling out such
matrices so you take only matrices where
lambda 1 and I call it lambda 1 it
could've been any lambda but I can
rename it lambda 1 right so okay maybe I
should well I suppose writing can be any
lambda
rename then we want to claim basically
that the limit as you raise it to a
power with some scaling becomes Rank 1
and that Rank 1 vector is a top
eigenvector right so that is important
so why is that that's just an obvious
calculation so now a to the S and I'm
going to divide the 1 over lambda 1 to
this absolute value you sum over T
equals 1 to R I erased well I wrote it
down that lambda T to there over lambda
1 to the S right and we get a to the S
so the lambda 1 to the S term sorry
UT UT transpose and then the lambda 1
term in the limit as X goes to infinity
the lambda 1 term becomes u 1 u 1
transpose the other terms go to 0
because lambda T 2 there over lambda 1
to the S goes to 0 because the absolute
value is less right okay so the other
terms go away only one term remains and
we will see a little later today or the
next lecture the power method which is
actually just a method for computing so
you can ask how do you compute singular
values and singular vectors
we saw the greedy algorithm which said
if I can compute the best straight line
I can find the best fit two dimensional
subspace three dimension and so on but
how do I find the best fit line right
best fit line is a top singular vector
how do I find it this is how I find it
provided the matrix is symmetric I can
just take powers of it and sooner or
later I'll get pretty close to the top
singular vector not quite the vector
right but I get you one yuan transpose
it's easy to see that if I gave you you
any one transpose you can figure out you
want okay
so the power method is a way of in
principle finding the top singular
vector in principle doing the whole SVD
algorithmically right I say in principle
because some of you know already but I
mean there's all subject in numerical
analysis which is there were the
beautiful
complicated algorithms but power method
is in principle the starting point you
wouldn't actually implement that but
it's a starting point okay very good so
this was under this assumption this may
not hold and so we will state at the end
of this lecture the next lecture we will
state okay so this is one thing I should
I should back off a little bit in
numerical analysis usually you see the
power method and everything isn't stated
in terms of the gap between lambda 1 and
lambda 2 we don't want to say that
because we want absolute theorems so I
will tell you an absolute theorem
whether or not there's a gap okay I mean
it's not new or anything but that's not
the way it's formulated so we would like
a theorem that holds for all matrices
and we'll state that but at the moment I
assume you know some strict gap exists
between lambda 1 and lambda 2 then it's
true that I get to a rank 1 if it's not
true it if lambda 1 lambda 2 are equal
you won't you won't necessarily get rank
1 you can get to two terms here
okay good so but that's also used which
is not a subject but since they have too
few slides maybe I'll spend two minutes
on this this little fact is also used
for Markov chains now again I won't
actually prove things there but the
point is this in Markov chains you have
let's say n states you start with an
initial probability vector p0 so p0 I is
the initial probability of being in
state I and Markov chains what happens
the probability is just transformed
linearly so the next time around this is
time 1 p1 excuse me these are row
vectors P 1 is just P naught times the
transition probability matrix P this is
called transition probability matrix I
won't tell you what this is always it's
not my intention to go over Markov chain
so I'm not going to tell you what it is
all I'm going to tell you is that the T
step what happens at time T the
probabilities or just P naught times P
raised to the power T excuse me let me
use that I've used s 4 powers this is a
time s
and the big theorem in Markov chains is
if you run it forever under some
conditions but if you run it forever
you get two stationary probabilities
some steady-state probabilities which
are limiting probabilities so we want to
say this converges to a limiting
probabilities again it's not my
intention to prove it in detail but I
just want to tell you how the how that
what we have their works to prove that
so what happens for Markov chains is
that lambda 1 of P is 1 and everybody
else is greater it's not always true for
every chain but we assume this now then
we saw we see from there P 2 this
divided by lambda 1 to the S but this is
just 1 sorry lambda 1 is 1 exactly not
absolute value so this is just 1 that's
equal to P this and that converges to
just some top eigen value sorry top
eigenvector Rank 1 matrix and now if you
hit it with P naught so P naught times P
2 there converges to P naught this is a
dot product row vector and column vector
u 1 transpose right
what that says is whatever peanut is it
doesn't matter
I always converge to probabilities
proportional to u 1 this is just a
scalar right so always converge the
probability is proportional to u 1 right
1 fixed u 1 whatever peanut is so maybe
that's what writing and then we can
whatever V naught is we converge two
probabilities proportional to u 1 and
these are called the stationary
probabilities yeah yeah so I'm doing it
a good point I'm doing it only for P
symmetric thank you so you do have to
otherwise symmetrize it so P is
symmetric yeah so this is not valid if
it's not symmetric Thanks
so you can stay in Markov chains is not
the subject of this file all I'm saying
is it's just a matrix it's just a matrix
in incoming equation or whatever okay
later we'll see power method we won't
see Markov chains okay now I want to
prove so that's okay that slide wasn't
just using orthogonality of singular
vectors it's essentially like you would
use alternative eigenvectors for
spectral decomposition there are a lot
of uses in here all right okay so now I
want to prove that SVD actually is not
just we did see that it's best in some
sense but I'm going to prove that it's
best in another sense so we want to
define here's a rank K matrix a.k.a k is
defined as the sum of the first K terms
alone of their sweetie this is often
called a truncated SVD so if you go to
MATLAB or something like that there's
always codes for finding the truncated a
sweetie so that takes only the top K
terms so Sigma one was the highest
remember and so on the top K terms top K
singular values and singular vectors
will show that for each k a k is the
best approximation to a of rank k okay
we want to show that sounds very much
like what we said already that VK is the
bestit subspace in fact it uses that
it's it is more or less that but we will
prove that this is true so for this
reason in a lot of computations if you
want to reduce the rank of a and still
get something decent a decent
approximation you use there sweetie
right it is the best possible
approximation so this is in in a sense
the reason SVD is used a lot
this send an analog of this will prove
also for the spectral norm a little
later so I did so this proof first right
first arrows away or projections of the
corresponding rows away into V K the
space spanned by V 1 to V key I want to
say we fought this capital VK yesterday
and also these are the singular vectors
right these are the right singular
vectors throughout this talk I'll use U
and V for the right for there sorry you
for the left V for the right singular
vectors so first we want to prove this
ok so and this is just some simple
calculation for so if I take any vector
a the projection of a onto VK so VK
capital indicates the subspace spanned
by these vectors and these are a basis
because they are orthonormal right
they're all VK so that's the basis so
you take its dot product rejection on
each basis vector and add them up that
is the projection onto the whole space
so that's for one particular vector a
now protecting each row of a into the ek
we get this okay and this is just also
equal to a k so I want to say that these
two are equal I just do I just see how
it is the case so I missed one step
there it's probably I mean just in
between the first and the second
equation
which is just that I equals 1 to K I'm
going to write out a write a is T equals
1 to R Sigma T u TV that's a and then I
have another VI VI transpose and again
this is a dot product it's zero unless T
equals I so you get if T equals I it's
one because length one this product is
the length of V T if T equals I or T
equals I and then you get you get a next
step and that's aching okay okay theorem
for any matrix B of rank K this is true
that says that a K is the best rank
approximation right because whatever me
fix I take the error is less for a k
than for P less than or equal to so the
proof take B that minimizes that among
all rank K or less matrices I don't have
to keep saying it but this minimum
exists right again the set of rank a
matrices looks unbounded but it's not so
you have to convince yourself you have
to convince yourself that minimum makes
this but it does so so to see that first
we argue that each row of B is a
projection of the corresponding row way
into the subspace V spanned by the
rosary right so I want to claim this and
the proof is if that's not the case
so if if a row B had a component which
is not equal to the projection on the
corresponding space of V we can instead
replace it by that replace that row by
the row of a projected onto V okay that
replacement doesn't increase the
dimension because that's still in the
space of V therefore the rank of V
doesn't go up rank of B doesn't go up
that's important we are we are still
dealing with the rank
matrix but I reduced a minus B squared
because I now made that row projection
of this row on to the space originally
it wasn't so again this was a row of a
this is a subspace V right and my B was
somewhere here instead I made it this
and this is the best you can do right
this is the least it's a perpendicular
distance to be okay there used to be
some other point and B in V but I made
it the perpendicular one so that's the
best so that reduces strictly reduces
because I had a component stick here it
is a minus B which is a contradiction to
the assumption that a minus this means
contradiction right so that means a
minus B is the best we started with a
man has be best so we cannot reduce it
so that proves this theorem I'm sorry
it's not doesn't prove yet work it's one
more step so a minus B squared is the
sum of squared distances of a to V right
so B we're all projections of the rows
of a so it's the perpendicular distance
of the rows of a with your data points
to V so that so among all vector spaces
of dimension K VK is the one that
minimizes that and that spanned by a K
so we get that this is from our old
theorem that we had main theorem we had
now it's also true for spectral norm
will prove that that is a little more
work it's not it's a little less obvious
but it's also true it's also true for
spectral norm it's actually true for
somewhat more general class of norms but
certainly for these two important ones
for being is no spectral so that's a
nice thing where it's really not only
that greedy works but it's the best
approximation in the two norms that
you're interested when the error is
measured in the two norms that are most
interesting so this
this will come a little later in today's
lecture okay so now I want for that I
need also that the left singular vectors
orthogonal so I must prove the U is
orthogonal again the right singular
vectors were all toggled by definition
because I said we choose alternative
even but we use that's not necessarily
true so we have to prove this so this is
a variational argument in a sense you
can use this argument also to prove the
main theorem but we this kind of
argument but we'll prove this here now
so it's a variational argument that says
if something is violated if they were
not also gional I can improve matters a
little bit so let's go back one step in
the case of these right if we want and
v2 are not orthogonal that's they make a
dot product then I can improve v1 by
adding a little bit of v2 into it that's
the kind of argument we are going to see
now but for the use because these were
already out of them suppose they are not
orthogonal take the smallest integers
that the V Y is not orthogonal to some
other u J so you I try and now we want
to assume that actually they make a
positive dot product I just assumed they
were not orthogonal but it may be that
they make a negative dot product but
then what do I do i I want to I want to
really assume they make a positive dot
product for the argument so why is that
why is it that I can assume that what if
they made a negative yes just a negative
so yeah replace it by the negative of
right if this was replaced UI or UJ by
it's negative but that's still a
singular vector so we may assume that we
also have that J must be greater than I
that's because J that's because I was
the smallest to violate orthogonality
with anybody so it cannot be violating
it with the earlier ones
the earlier ones were all alright must
be the later once it's violating is it
so J must be greater than I so here's a
variational argument right so I take the
right singular vector VI and I'm going
to perturb it slightly epsilon here is
infinite decimal okay so I'm going to
assume epsilon was introduced much so
second order terms can be thrown out so
I'm going to take VI and add a little
bit of VJ to it so I might have said it
wrong earlier but this is correct that
UI and UJ or Norrell total I'm going to
add a little bit of VJ to VI I added
that I must make the length one so I do
that so this thing has length one now
and I'm going to show you VI prime is
better than VI which is a contradiction
VI was the best fit orthogonal to some
other things I'm going to show you VI
prime is a better fit and that can't be
right
so a VI prime let's see what it is a VI
VI was a singular vector so a VI is
Sigma I UI right if it was an
eigenvector a VA would be lambda lambda
IVI singular vector Sigma UI and then
similarly this you get epsilon sigma j
UJ if you're looking at the book some of
these indices or wrong there but i
corrected them now the length of this
this is length one length one but these
two are orthogonal VA m VJ right there
already a thorn oh so the length is just
photographers 1 plus epsilon squared but
square root it's important that I have
only epsilon square only a second-order
term here if I had a first-order term
this wouldn't work so these are being
already orthogonal is what gives me the
second-order term there so a VI prime
I'm going to prove has is a better fit
than VI so it it's long so I want to say
its length is high this vector this is a
vector it's length is how I want to say
well it's at least as high as the
component along UI right UI is a unit
vector so if I take the dot product of
UI in this I get something certainly the
length of this is at least that much it
has other components perhaps so it's at
least a component along UI so you take a
dot product here you get UI transpose ah
they're still wrong
that's UI sorry that's what do you want
that was UI that so that's you I this
should be UI I'll correct that that
should be UI so we get Sigma I it's UI
transpose UI is length 1 so you get sick
mind and and this is epsilon Sigma u J
oh yeah this is still u J that's still
UI sorry
so UI UI transpose u i's once they get
Sigma UI transpose UJ is Delta so you
get Delta Epsilon Sigma Delta and this
I've written that's the square root of I
think that's just absolutely true right
so I get 1 over 1 plus epsilon squared
times 1 minus epsilon squared over 2 is
less than 1 right
yeah I think if you square this you get
1 minus epsilon squared plus something
yeah I hope I didn't make mistakes
though no minus epsilon square plus
epsilon to the fourth over 4 yeah one
mind it's not quite right so but III may
have not made a but but anyway it's a
second-order term so epsilon is infinite
decimal 1 over square root of 1 plus
epsilon squared is second order only
second order terms comfort if I do a
Taylor expansion of that
I'm if I didn't do that right think it's
equal to one one - doesn't matter what
the constant is okay so I multiply this
out I get I most important I get a
first-order term here the rest are
second order terms but the first order
term is positive right that's all I'm
that's all I care about the first order
term is positive and therefore I get
something greater than Sigma so that was
greater than Sigma there so all I care
about is that these two were orthogonal
so the denominator of a second order and
the first order term is still positive
coefficient well now as they absorb as
infinitesimal so Delta whoa okay so
Delta is not infinitely small because
use or fixed so I have you i dot u I
transpose D I assumed it's positive it's
a fixed positive quantity and alpha
epsilon is much smaller than Delta
choose so this is a variation argument
right variation argument just means this
you you had infinite just won't show
that something is violated assuming you
guys are unit length but they were
assumed they were normalized to length
one so you I was defined as you I was
defined as a VI divided by length of a
via so they are they're already unit
length okay so so this says that we got
something greater than Sigma for the
length of this vector now this is a
contradiction because VI plus epsilon V
J so is orthogonal to the previous V so
remember VI was the best orthogonal to
the previous ones I produce something
which is better but I must say also that
it's orthogonal to the previous ones to
get a contradiction right so it is
orthogonal to the previous ones
since J is greater than I so VI and VJ
were both orthogonal to all of these
therefore the sum is okay so I needed
that VI and VJ are both orthogonal to
the previous one and Sigma is defined
with the maximum over all such vectors
so it's a contradiction okay so the UI's
are orthogonal so I'm going to use that
but I need one more level I'm still
trying to prove a case the best fit in
spectral norm I'm not there yet I need
one more level so I need to prove that a
minus akk spectral norm now it's just
the next thing you know vector singular
value and the proof of this so let me
step back a step this lecture is
probably the most technical because I
have a lot of details to work out maybe
I should tell you the agenda just to
take a break from this and then we'll do
this calculation so what will happen
after this in the next few lectures
including possibly today's some of it is
will see the power method with an
absolute theorem absolute meaning no gap
assumptions possible today possibly not
and then we will see how SVD helps us
learn a mixture of two gaussians
so I introduced Gaussian mixtures and
will I'll redefine them but it helps us
learn a mixture sorry kegels any number
of gaussians but there are spherical
gaussians only for this and this is in a
way a clustering problem we saw that
we'll also see that SVD leads to what's
called spectral clustering now this is
in Chapter seven of the book not this
chapter so spectral clustering is a very
widely used technique for clustering not
just mixtures so this is also spectral
clustering so first we do it for
Gaussian mixtures then we'll do it a
little more generally that's a rough
agenda right for what follows I may
preview the power method at least today
I don't have slides but I'll preview the
power method and then it'll come back
and continue with that and do these
things there's one topic I did not
mention and we'll do it if there's time
which is that length squared sampling
to compute SVD
this is in a different chapter as well I
think it's chapter six or eight so the
gist of this is that if you want to do
SVD of a big matrix you can do length
squared sampling to pick some rows and
just to SVD of that rectangular matrix
consisting of those rows that gives you
a good approximation provable
approximation right for any matrix so
the gist of this is SVD on length
squared sample rolls gives you a
guarantee on what the error is
I'm a permute these topics so that I do
perhaps this before that but we'll send
Lee to the power method and Gaussian
mixture vertical Gaussian mixture okay
so that is a relief from the technical
detail but now we'll go back to the
technical detail so always I want to
prove that a - aka spectral norm is just
Sigma K so SVD is that a - a K so a K
subtracter of the first K terms so I go
go k plus 1 to R so I want to prove that
the spectral norm of this is not very
bad is equal to that thing so let V be
the top singular vector of that spectral
norm is defined by V of course right so
we we can express V as a linear
combination of V 1 through VR so why is
that so V was a top singular vector of a
- a K which is these things right in
fact in fact it's it's even true that
it's expressed as a combination I should
have said you don't need to use V 1
through all of we are right what these
is what we tease or what these sub i's
is via combination of I mean it's just
it's a top singular vector
this matrix right so you'll only involve
VK plus one through we are anything else
is useless right anything else is a
waste right if I put something other
than these V's I'm wasting lengths and
getting nothing getting zero so I'll
only put that so but here I put all
hours I think but anyway you get this
calculation so now you do that so I put
all hours although again very soon it
comes down to that so all again the same
same thing that VI transpose VJ 0 unless
I equals day and so I only goes this k
plus 1 to all J also only goes that much
and those go away that inner product is
a length one and so you get Sigma I see
is sorry that was the C from there and
you get this ladies are also normals so
think squared is just a sum of squares
Isis Pythagoras and we are maximizing V
a maximizing sorry maximizing this thing
because V is a singular vector the top
singular vector of a minus a case so
this needs to be maximized and the
maximum is attained when Sigma K plus 1
is the highest of the slot so CK plus 1
is 1 right all the way it should be put
on the highest rest of 0 and therefore
that's true and then finally a K is the
best best rank approximation is work so
for B of rank K I want to prove that a -
a K B is no better than a K KB is worse
than a inspector but now we put a 2
there right it's for that it's for for
Binion's norm B with respect to long so
if rank of a for so first case if rank
of a is K or less it's trivial because
then a minus a K is 0 right
a K takes away the top K terms ok so if
the rank is K or less then
take away everything okay so zeroes of
course less than or equal to anything
like that that's non negative so nothing
to prove so we assume that the rank of a
is greater than or equal to K so a minus
a K spectral norm we already know that
we knew that from the last slide now I
take the null space of B it has
dimensional least P minus K that's
because the rank of B is at most K so
the null space is dimension at least P
minus K null space I mean so let's say D
is smaller than n so D minus K dimension
dimension counts imply now there's a
vector and a null space of B which is
also in the span of these so why is that
this has dimension D minus K this has
dimension K plus one so if I take two
subspaces the dimension adds up to more
than D there's always a nonzero vector
in the in the intersection okay I mean
this linear algebra that you should
prove right dimension together is more
than d if it's d or less this need not
be so if it's d for instance the first
sub space could be the first unit vector
the next one would be all the other d
minus 1 the dimensions out of only two d
there's nothing in the intersection
nothing non zero in the intersection
zero is the only thing right but if it's
d plus 1 you have to prove that there's
somebody in a null space so maybe I
won't prove that value you certainly I
mean it's just basically a matter of
fact you can check that that's true now
you scales that to be of length 1 I can
always do that and still be in this
still be in the subspaces now what can
we say with that so a minus B I'm trying
to prove is not too small so it's bigger
than at least what that does to a minus
B this is this spectral norm right
there's a max over all vectors certainly
is greater than or equal to what happens
it's said
now be said is zero so this is just
equal to a Zed
now easy that belongs to the span of the
first K plus-1 singular vectors of a so
a Zed I can write again this way I and I
just did the dot product squared now why
is this so this is the length squared
these are scalars right and these are
orthonormal so you just take the square
of sum of squares of the components
components along UI UJ rather I guess no
it's UI so you get that and that's equal
to Sigma I squared VI transpose that
that is only in the span of these so I
go only up to k plus 1 there the
restaurant count that's greater than or
equal to now I equals 1 to k plus 1 the
Sigma's or decreasing so the least of
them is Sigma k plus 1 squared it comes
out and you get that and that's equal
this is 1 because this is a length of
that like that isn't a span of these
things so I took all its components
squared and added so you get Sigma K
plus 1 squared so I proved that in the
spectral norm that's the best so that
that took us the most work so a K is the
best rank approximation to a in both
Frobenius and spectral alone so this is
the main reason a sweetie is so useful
right so you can find most times
optimization problems are not solvable
in polynomial time there and be hard but
this is an optimization problem we can
solve in polynomial time we can find the
best fit subspace we can find the best
rank k approximation today in both these
senses
okay so I think I ran out of slides but
I'm what I'm going to do is probably do
preview of a power method on the board
unless there are questions or discussion
we can take a two-minute break to see if
there are any anybody has any questions
so this works I think for all unitarily
invariant knobs saturn norm is not clear
because you you get powers higher than
two so photograph's and everything is
not true but unitary invariants
so perturbation results you want okay
that's a good point yeah so I didn't
yeah I should have done some
perturbation tonight so here is the kind
of suppose I want Sigma K of a plus B in
terms of Sigma's of a and B what can I
say in general I mean I can say good
things for specific matrices but what
can I say in general unfortunately the
only thing we can say in general this is
less than or equal to Sigma K of a but
here we have to put signal 1 okay so
that is true right now why is so you
prove these kinds of this anything like
this you prove by taking the Kate
singular vector of one of these things
of either a or a plus B and yeah so I
wonderful this is greater than or equal
to so I take the singular vectors of
this a plus B singular vectors
and then I argue that Sigma kill a
I have a suspicion I may not be able to
prove it on the spot okay but it is true
this inequality is true I do pay for you
know this could be very high it would
have been nice if I said Sigma K VA plus
Sigma K of B it's not true so this is
all I can say right maybe I want I won't
actually prove this but you could you
could ask suppose B is very small B is
noise right
how much do singular values get
perturbed that's one thing you could ask
right so there is something called the
Hofmann violent inequality which is very
nice inequality dips and that says the
following sum over
let me risk writing this Sigma Sigma K
squared of this minus Sigma K squared of
a i1 so I'm going to try to say that
this is less than or equal to this I
could be wrong and I think I could have
to take I may have to take a square of
this and add and get a fourth power so
the Hoffman V only record is often
stated for eigen values of symmetric
matrices and you get singular values
just by taking symmetric matrices a plus
B times a plus B transpose so don't
worry for the moment about the exact
inequality you can look it up what the
the idea is that if B is not very big
then I don't change singular values very
much right which is what you would
expect that's what this is saying so the
right hand side depends on B if B for
instance B is 0 of course you should get
0 on the other side it is this is 0 this
says it's less than or equal to
that's one kind of theorem that that
that's nice to know so I want to a
perhaps point out another kind of
theorem since we since they ask for
perturbation results which is what
happens if you have a random matrix
so first if you have a random symmetric
what does that mean that means a IJ j
greater than I or IIT let's say normal 0
1 and a I J I J less than I by symmetric
about diagonal entries are independent
random variables
I want the matrix to be symmetric so
below diagonal entries better be equal
to the about angle entries right
corresponding ones and the expected
value of each entry is 0 and the
variance is 1 now we we know that then
the length of sorry the length of a I
squared sum over all IJ that's the
Frobenius norm of a squid and I want the
expected value of that random variable
so the Frobenius norm of a Frobenius
norm of a squared is just a sum of the
squares right the expectation can go in
is just the sum expectation of the sum
of some other expectations right even
independence yeah so these are these
expectations about diagonal well I
didn't say anything about the diagonals
so let's say that aii are all 0 they
could also be normal 0 1 maybe I'll just
make a is also normal 0 1 excuse me they
don't matter too much so each entry has
variance 1 so you get N squared
and we saw that this is the sum of the
singular values
so that implies Sigma 1 squared away is
less than or equal to a squared which
should be less than or equal to N
squared
CN squared with high probability so why
is that right the Frobenius norm in
expectations M squared only an
expectation but to sum of many
independent variables so it's not going
to be greater than CN squared right we
saw that sum of independent variables
the tail bounds are good so this won't
be very large with high probability
this stands for with high probability
and so Sigma 1 squared is less than N
squared in general Sigma 1 squared can
be if a is Rank 1 Sigma 1 squared equals
a squared right Sigma 1 squared equals
that's true but in fact for random in
this set up that's in general in this
set up we can the theorem is that with
high probability Sigma 1 squared away or
Sigma 1 away it was less than or equal
to let's see I think it's root 2 or
maybe I should just say it's
asymptotically about from two root ends
now what's nice about this this is hard
to prove this I mean this I am NOT going
to prove here write this the reason it's
hard to prove is that this is the max
over all X over X right so to prove this
you must prove that for every one of
these infinitely many X must prove for
every X that's true so that's not the
subject of this lecture so I won't be
able to prove that but I want to point
out one thing before we go on and the
one thing is the length of one row
length the one row of a is itself as
large as root n so let me let me do the
expected length squared or one row of a
is equal to sum over J expectation of a
I squared these are all ones that's then
so one rows as long and a singular value
it says is that most the length of under
all times a constant now that's quite
striking right that won't be true for
arbitrary matrices why is that quite
striking because of the following
sigma-1 of Nea is greater than or equal
to the length of a times the first row
okay written as a column that's equal to
the length of a one squid greater than
or equal so I take the first row dot
product with this right so that's the
length quit the square sorry so I have
to divide by a one I have to do I have
to make unit length vector so certainly
it's true that Sigma one is trivially
greater than or equal to this I'm even
ignoring the contribution of the other
rows the other rows may make a good
drawer product with a 1/2 so this is
telling you that the rows are
uncorrelated right you know random
matrix I take the first row I get about
root and I really almost get nothing
from the other rows I only get a
constant factor more so it's as if the
rows or in in a sense uncorrelated and
they are they're independent random
variables so it for one thing says sorry
this thing implies the rows are
uncorrelated
so random matrices he sees a one extreme
but SVD is used for totally unrendered
matrices in practice so let's say what
that is so typical user SVD so this
again I was going to go over next time
but I'll try that now typically the SVD
is principal component analysis
principal component analysis or PCA says
replace a by a K and just compute a key
this is only good if the first gate if
the truncation leaves very later we just
saw that the error it leaves is in
spectral norm is the k plus first
singular value so if this is much
smaller than let's say Sigma 1 this is
an interesting thing to do so in
practice you use this a lot for matrices
which have this property so useful if
Sigma K plus 1 is much much smaller than
Sigma 1 but for random matrices is not
true because Sigma 1 itself for a random
matrix Sigma 1 itself is order root n
yeah Sigma 1 is order routine and the
sum of the squares of all of them is N
squared right that's the Frobenius norm
which is order n square so Sigma 1 is
basically just about the average in
square right so Sigma 1 squared is more
or less with an it is within a constant
factor of the average Sigma T squared so
there are n of these the total is n
squared
the average is n n square and Sigma 1 is
only about that so it's far from having
this inequality so this and this
so if it's a random matrix you should
not use PCA right the assertion is in
practice lot of matrices have this
property that Sigma K plus 1 is much
more than Sigma 1 ok that's that's why
you use PCA
sorry
is it easier for enemy disease actually
I don't know no I don't know that I mean
like I don't know an algorithm which for
random it is the easier or faster right
in fact there's a vague folklore that is
harder because the gaps are smaller so
random matrices are often thought to be
the hardest sort of yeah so it may be
that so for instance one conjecture
would be that if I pick a random subset
there will be a singular vector just in
the span of those yeah I think some
things like that might be true I don't
know proofs of those things the
numerical iterative methods which don't
sample certainly for them random
matrices are thought to be hard because
the gaps are bad but the suggestion
maybe that's what you're making is a
right if I pick a few random rows in
their span I should have a good singular
vector that's possible yeah I don't know
proof that something quantitative works
like that so I will stop here because I
don't have anything more to say but if
on Monday we'll come back and do the
power method I didn't do the power
method but yeah
yes that is the 3d computation so it's a
little more complicated length squared
sampling SVD that was one of the topics
I put up later but maybe I will move it
up come to think of it but it's
complicated but it's more complicated
than multiplication or or compressed
representation okay yeah so okay so
maybe we will move that up in the agenda
but first we do the power method because
it means nice no Dept and okay so first
we'll do the power method and then we'll
I'm Gaussian mixtures spherical Gaussian
mixture is also both nice to know and
then maybe we'll dress we deal with
length right something